the gyro can experience how did you get
involved in grappling how do you have
time to turbocharge Ferraris like where
do you come up with the extra time to do
all those other things so you know I
like to tell people that I one of my
pitches is like you should always get
enough sleep
like I I do not work well like I said I
can't work more than 13 hours if I if I
don't get eight hours of sleep I also
start falling down but there's a lot
hours left in the week after you're
eight hours of sleep there
I like on the martial arts side it's it
is kind of interesting where I I
wrestled in junior high and I did sort
of Midwest YMCA judo back then I wasn't
any kind of a phenom I was you know sort
of a second-place finisher for most of
it but it was still weird enough that
the [ __ ] and of the school geek was
pretty good at that type of stuff I am I
messed up my knees a little bit doing
that and in retrospect I wish I had
pushed on a little bit more with that
where in recent years I sort of tried to
challenge the the wrestler ethos that I
embrace the grind to people where it's
just like discipline is a something I
was always obsessed but I could have
done with a little more discipline I am
when I was younger and I probably would
have been better off if I had I kind of
stuck through some of the the wrestling
side of things I am but I got back into
it in my 30s where it was kind of
something I'm just again one of the
between projects well what interesting
thing do I want to take a look at and I
looked up some of the local judo places
and it was interesting where the place
that I wound out was called Becerra judo
and I had come again from Midwest YMCA
judo which is just kind of you know you
go and you learn your moves and it's
it's not that serious
but this was a I you know he was a Cuban
Olympian and it's still judo's mostly
kids you get mostly I kind of teenage
kids coming in but I go in there and
he's just yelling at the kids and
berating him it's like get up grab the
guy and all this stuff
much more serious training environment
but I got in there it's like hey I did
wrestling and judo back when I was a
teenager 20 years ago at that point but
I got on the mat rolled and I had enough
kind of wrestler instinct memories that
I you know I'd go down I base out and
then the guy would roll me over an
armbar me like three times in a row cuz
you know early teens I YMCA didn't teach
you the arm bars or anything I'm but
that was enough it's like hey I was
having a good time with that and so I
did what I always do on something I
studied you know I went and said well
okay I let's learn these arm bars and
things and I got them you know the
instructionals and the tapes and started
working my way back through that and got
pretty good at that and then my wife for
Christmas one year got me a year of
private lessons with Carlos Machado oh
wow yeah
and that was where I certainly took me
up several levels where I was in a
situation where I had my armadillo
aerospace my rocketry company at the
time we had enough space so I had a
bunch of mats set out there and I would
work with Carlos and one of the other
guys there on Saturdays and you really
tuned me up where I had a really good
straight arm bar that was my go-to move
for everything and against most of the
judo people that I it was just most of
them wouldn't know what hit them on that
I would just be able to get that over
and over again and there was a period
there where I had I am you know I'd go
mix it up at the club on one day and
then I had judo with one of my coaches
another day and then Carlos on Saturday
there was a period there where I was
pretty dangerous although I was I was
always one of the I never did workout
proper flow kind of just the way to just
kind of roll effortlessly I was always a
very tense aggressive I kind of grappler
and an interesting thing about that
where you know you know from rolling
with any of the the really good guys I
like rolling with Carlos it's always
happy fun he's smiling and you always
think you should be able to do something
but just actually can't but in contrast
with that one time when I went to Japan
I stopped in at the Kodokan you know the
home of Judo kind of the ancestral land
of Judo and you know it's funny we're
talking with a friend about that I that
also did some judo where you'd think
that that should be like going to the
Jedi Temple it should be this majestic
thing but it looks like an old middle
school when you go there until you
actually get out onto the mats there but
I remember I I did some rolling with an
old judo guy you know gray-haired guy
practicing his English with me and it
was shocking how different it was versus
rolling with Carlos we're silly was way
way better than me but it was a sense
where when I was rolling with he
I just felt I had no options like for
whatever reason I was just always bound
up and I couldn't do anything until
eventually gets my arm and I tap as
opposed to the fluidness with Carlos
where I'm like running around thinking
off I just do this maybe I'll be able to
get you know get around yes playing yeah
yeah jujitsu is very famous for playing
my instructors his brother yeah yeah you
said you messed your knees up so of
course back then I had tweaked my knees
in some way where it wasn't bad enough
that I had maybe at the time I should
have had surgery but I did the jiu-jitsu
training no this was actually back in
write one in wrestling and one in judo
when I was a teenager and so that's why
I've still got these little stick legs
cuz I could never lift what you know
heavy weights I've because my knees gave
me problems so I wound up with strong
upper body and really nothing on though
on the legs did you get your knees and
Miraj I never did you know again this
was back in the day like you not embrace
MRIs well so again this was the 80s yeah
they did but it's like you know I was
not know it was teenage me back then and
it was like okay my knees are hurt a
little bit no so by the time I was in my
30s they generally felt okay so that was
when I decided I'm gonna go back into
Judo and and it's been alright for quite
a while and it's you know it's
interesting there were a lot of people
are surprised that I care about this
like I tweeted about going to the UFC in
Dallas and there are a number of people
that are like you know this is shocking
and disappointing that you you know that
you like you know seeing people harm
each other
I had there's one interesting thing at
the club where there was a new kid that
came in and I could tell he was probably
here because his dad thought he should
toughen up a little bit I've you know a
very not forceful person I am and when
he found out who I was he said what is
someone like you doing here and it just
didn't compute for him that I somebody
that was a technical I kind of brainy
sort of person would appreciate my kind
of rolling at a judo club and and I
probably agree with his his father that
there's a there is a value to getting
getting people into a sense where they
felt the physicality of it they've had
to push as hard as they can and maybe
not get through yeah
learn that find the extents of what you
can and can't do and what the limits of
your body are and I think that's good
for almost everybody to get that at some
level I mean even if you don't care
about the competition and the winning
but kind of knowing what's possible and
the different limits there I think is
valuable I agree wholeheartedly and I
love the fact that you got into it
because I would like to encourage so
many more people to experience that
there are there's many things going on
simultaneously there's a technical
aspects of the various moves they have
to understand the points of leverage and
how to get to a superior position
there's also the physical exertion
aspect where you're you're managing your
body's resources and you have a finite
amount of energy and you can't burn it
all out quickly so there's this sort of
management game that you're playing and
then on top of it it's like you you have
to be able to be uncomfortable it's you
have to be able to put yourself in a
good state of mind while you're
uncomfortable and so many of those
lessons learn from that or applicable to
everyday life and they they give you a
higher threshold for discomfort a higher
threshold for pushing through obstacles
and understanding boundaries and how to
overcome them and how to increase your
physical engine how to strengthen your
your meat vehicles yeah that whole
lesson about you know sometimes you're
the hammer and sometimes you're the nail
and a lot of people do go through much
of their life I have you know without
ever really internalizing that it's
always you know participation trophy or
whatever but it's like sometimes you get
your ass kicked
and that can bring it you can come back
stronger after yes it's good for you
it's actually good for you and it's an
amazing camaraderie this is particularly
grappling I found that grappling the
camaraderie is much nicer than striking
I came from a striking background
because the thing about striking all
there is a camaraderie a deep
camaraderie with people that you would
go and compete with you're hurting each
other yeah whereas in grappling you're
not really hurting each other the same
way and you can kind of do it full blast
and you appreciate each other because
iron truly does sharpen iron it yeah I
mean there are so many times I remember
just driving back from the ayah from
Judo where
just have a big smile on my face just
thinking that was really great yeah now
it's like the judo club was in AI you
know a little bit of a sketchier area of
town so my wife was always like you can
never drive your Ferraris to judo
practice
[Applause]